REPORTING, DRONES ARE PLAYING A
KEY ROLE IN UKINE'S
COUNTEROFFENSIVE AGAINST
RUSSIA'S INVASION.
ONE IS PROVING SO EFFECTIVE THAT
UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE SINGING ITS
PRAISES LITERALLY.
CNN'S JOMANA KARADSHEH HAS THIS
EXCLUSIVE REPORT.
>> Reporter: THIS UKRAINIAN SONG
HAS GONE VIRAL IN UKRAINE AND
BEYOND.
IT'S AN ODE TO A DRONE.
THE TURKISH-MADE WEAPON
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS ARE TOUTING
AS ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE IN
THEIR ARSENAL THAT'S PLAYED A
PART IN SLOWING DOWN THE
RUSSIAN' ADVANCE.
IT'S BEEN OPERATIONAL FOR YEARS,
DESCRIBED AS A GAME-CHANGER IN
RECENT CONFLICTS LIKE LIBYA.
BUT IT IS UKRAINE THAT IS
CATAPULTED IT TO WORLDWIDE FAME.
ITS SUCCESS, NOT ONLY ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
VIDEOS OF STRIKES AGAINST
RUSSIAN MILITARY TARGETS, LIKE
THIS ONE RELEASED BY UKRAINE'S
MINISTRY OF DEFENSE ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, HAVE ALSO MADE IT A KEY
PART OF UKRAINE'S INFORMATION
WAR.
WE HAVE GOTTEN RARE ACCESS TO
THIS PRODUCTION FACILITY HERE IN
TURKEY BUT BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF THIS INDUSTRY, WE ARE VERY
RESTRICTED IN WHAT WE CAN FILM
AND WHAT WE CAN SHOW.
THE DRONE'S CREATOR GIVES US A
MOSTLY OFF-CAMERA TOUR OF THE
DEFENSE COMPANY'S HEADQUARTERS
IN ISTANBUL.
THE COMPANY'S PRIDE, TURKEY'S
FIRST UNMANNED FIGHTER JET HAS
JUST HIT THE PRODUCTION LINE BUT
THE CENTERPIECE HERE IS THE
DRONE EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT.
>> IT IS A TACTICAL CLASS UAV
AND IT'S DOING WHAT IT WAS
DESIGNED TO DO, AND WHAT IT WAS
OPERATED TO DO.
>> Reporter: IN THIS EXCLUSIVE
CNN INTERVIEW, HE MEASURES HIS
WORDS CAREFULLY.
HE IS ALSO THE SON-IN-LAW OF THE
TURKISH PRESIDENT, WHO MAINTAINS
CLOSE TIES WITH BOTH RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE AND HAS EMERGED AS A KEY
MEDIATOR.
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T WANT TO
BE -- BRAG ABOUT -- GIVING THEIR
LIVES UP, PEOPLE ARE RISKING AND
DEFENDING THEIR HOMELAND FROM AN
ILLEGAL OCCUPATION.
THAT'S WHAT BRAVE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE AND ITS LEADERSHIP HAS
DONE.
JUST AT THE SAME TIME, OF
COURSE, YOU NEED TECHNOLOGY.
YOU NEED, YOU KNOW, HIGH-TECH
AND YOU NEED YOUR OWN INDIGENOUS
DEFENSE CAPACITY.
BUT WHEN PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE ON
THE LINE AND WHEN CHILDREN
ARE -- EVEN CHILDREN ARE DYING
AND CIVILIANS ARE DYING, I DON'T
WANT TO COMPARE THAT TO ANY SORT
OF TECHNOLOGY.
>> Reporter: TURKEY'S DRONE
SALES TO KYIV HAVE BEEN A MAJOR
IRRITANT FOR RUSSIA LONG BEFORE
THIS WAR.
UKRAINE GOT ITS FIRST IN 2019.
IT'S ORDERED AT LEAST 36 OF
THOSE DRONES SO FAR.
BUT IT'S NOT ONLY A CLIENT.
IT PRODUCES ENGINES FOR THE MORE
ADVANCED DRONE AND WAS ABOUT TO
BEGIN CO-PRODUCING TURKISH
DRONES.
PLANS THAT WERE DISRUPTED BY THE
INVASION.
HE HEARD THE SONG DEDICATED TO
HIS NAMESAKE DRONE.
HE KNOWS VERY WELL THE
PHENOMENON IT HAS BECOME IN
UKRAINE.
>> I THINK IT IS ONE OF THE
SYMBOLS OF RESISTANCE.
IT GIVES THEM HOPE I THINK.
>> Reporter: HOPE IN A BATTLE
UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING ON ALL
FRONTS.
>> THE DRONES ARE PART OF THE
LARGER SOCIAL MEDIA CAMPAIGN
THAT IS EXECUTED VERY WELL BY
THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY AND
CIVILIANS, AND THEY ARE CREATING
THE IMPRESSION THAT THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY IS, IN FACT, LOSING AND
THAT THE RUSSIAN MILITARY IS
VULNERABLE.
AGAIN, BAYRAKTAR IS NOT THE ONLY
SOLUTION OUT THERE, AND IT ISN'T
NECESSARILY A SOLUTION THAT IS
GOING TO SAVE THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY BECAUSE AFTER ALL, THIS
IS A GROUND WAR.
BUT HAVING A DRONE LIKE
BAYRAKTAR IN THE SKY THAT CAN
CONDUCT SURVEILLANCE, THAT CAN
LAUNCH STRIKES, AND HAVING THE
VIDEOS OF THOSE STRIKES MULTIPLY
ON SOCIAL MEDIA IS A GREAT
MORALE BOOSTER.
IT IS, ALSO, A GREAT TACTICAL
VICTORY, AS WELL.
>> Reporter: THIS SOCIAL MEDIA
VIDEO SHOWS CIVILIANS IN THE
CITY OF KHERSON PROTESTING
AGAINST RUSSIAN FORCES.
THEY PLAY THEMED BAYRAKTAR SONG.
ONE OF THE COUNTLESS MOMENTS OF
RESISTANCE BY A NATION USING A